russia's war on ukraine is again
impacting the occupied crimea peninsula
russian officials say explosions at an
air base there have killed one person
and injured several others
videos shared on social media show
several large blasts at the novo
fedoreska facility
russia's defense ministry says the
explosions were detonations of stored
ammunition and not the result of any
attack
kiev denied any responsibility for the
incident
a senior ukrainian official suggested
the blasts may have been a work of
saboteurs inside crimea
russia illegally annexed crimea in 2014
an action that ukraine's president
vladimir zelinsky says was directly
connected to the current war
today there's a lot of attention on the
crimea issue
and rightly so because crimea is
ukrainian and we will never renounce it
we will not forget that it was the
occupation of crimea that was the
beginning of the russian war against
ukraine
dw correspondent matthias berlinga is
following the story from kiev i asked
him whether russia's claim that the
explosions were an accident seemed
plausible well yeah the ukrainian the
ministry of defense has said that it
advises the people in occupied crimea to
adhere to smoking regulations and russia
has said it was an accident but if you
look at the video footage that people
have shut from these explosions then
it's very clear that
an accidental fire is not very probable
two explosions happening at the same
time at two different locations that
pretty much looks like an attack um now
who did it and why and how um is another
question we have a several voices out of
the ukrainian government suggesting that
it might have either been a partisan
attack or some kind of a
rocket or uav attack um uh this is very
contradictive and that's probably
intended because uh ukraine wouldn't
want to give russia a clue about what
has been happening and wouldn't um uh
want russia to draw some consequences
in further cases um some security
regulations etc uh from this so um we
are at the moment we don't really know
what has happened but it's pretty clear
that this is a major strike on
russian uh military infrastructure there
that was it was a big aerodrome that was
used ukrainians say for attacks on
the ukrainian
inner territories and
we have also seen these were big
explosions a lot of ammunition several
planes destroyed so it's definitely a
military
success for ukraine and that's probably
also the reason why russia is not
admitting uh that it has been an attack
because it would make
it would make look russia pretty
vulnerable on crimea which is one of
their main
military
bases one of the most militarized places
in this region
as we all know matthias russia illegally
annexed crimea in 2014 and has occupied
it ever since if ukraine makes
sufficient gains in the current conflict
could we see ukraine trying to take back
crimea
if is the big question because at the
moment of course this looks pretty much
impossible whether the conditions will
change
in a way that uh uh ukraine might
attempt to take back crimea is of course
the big question is probably the last
one considering the last territory that
ukraine might try to take back
considering that it's pretty militarized
it's not as accessible as other
territories that russia is occupying
that was dw correspondent matthias
berlinga speaking to me a little while
here from kiev
and i'm joined now from london by
military analyst and conflict researcher
mike martin welcome to dw mike um can
you tell us who who do you think was
behind these explosions in crimea
of course it was the uh ukrainians um
we've heard this before from the
russians when the moskva sank your your
viewers will probably remember this
russian ship that sank there were all
sorts of stories
and then it turned out that actually the
ukrainians had fired a missile at it the
reason of course that the ukrainians are
being slightly coy about this they're
saying oh well you know maybe it was us
maybe it wasn't us it's because what
this does is it it spreads confusion and
fear amongst the russians and
particularly the russian forces based in
crimea and and just north of crimea and
her son and this is exactly what the
russians have been doing for the last 10
years so they're getting a taste of
their own medicine is there any
information available about the damage
that these explosions caused
uh
not with complete clarity what we do
know is that that base had a number of
um fairly advanced russian fighter
aircraft on them
prior to the explosion so we can assume
that at least and this this is sort of
eight to ten aircraft we can assume that
these have been damaged but what we do
also know is that there were some
explosions from either the partisan
attack or a missile strike or whatever
and then sometime later there was a much
larger series of explosions and what
that tells us is that
effectively the initial strike then set
off ammunition or fuel which is what
you'd expect to have on a base of that
size and so
the russians have lost quite a sizable
quantity and if you look at the pictures
sort of the mushroom cloud raising up
the russians have lost quite a sizable
quantity of fuel and ammunition
if this was a ukrainian attack does it
signify
a strategy a strategy shift from kiev
actually i think it's a continuation of
a strategy effectively what they're
doing by striking in crimea is pointing
out to the russians that nowhere on
occupied ukrainian territory is safe and
for the russians crimea is the most
important territory that they occupy
it's more important than donbass so if
the ukrainians can hit
the russians in crimea
what that will do is it will force the
russians to pull forces and defenses out
of other areas into crimea to defend it
and then that of course gives the
ukrainians more options about where they
want to attack next the momentum
really has shifted in this war it's now
the ukrainians that are dictating the
story whereas
previously it's been the russians that
have been forcing the ukrainians to
respond to them we've seen reports of
more russian shelling of central ukraine
overnight can you tell me tell us any
more about that
um
the shelling of civilian areas by
russia
is if you look at it in military terms
it doesn't achieve anything so when you
see the ukrainians striking russian
military targets and the russians
striking ukrainian civilian targets that
also tells us something it tells us that
russia is
feeling under pressure and feeling
somewhat powerless and it's striking out
at civilians because although attacks on
civilians obviously illegal and
obviously terrifying for those civilians
in strict military terms they don't
actually advance the russian cause at
all in fact they probably set it back
because as we've seen attacks on
civilians have galvanized the ukrainian
population
unified them to fight against the
russians
mike martin we'll have to leave it there
thanks so much for that really
fascinating analysis
thank you very much
you